Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch.
Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch. Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch. Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch. Ich bin ein sehr guter Mensch.
Du hast es im Vorbereitungssetum schon mal genau erklärt, woher das kommt, dass man im japanischen noch ungenauer sein kann als im deutschen. Das finde ich jetzt mal, glaube ich, für die Hörer auch spannend, woran das liegt.
Ja, das liegt daran, dass wenn man also mündlich spricht, das gilt vor allen Dingen für das Gesprochene, dann benutzt man halt besonders viele Höflichkeitsformen. Und bei den Höflichkeitsformen ist es so, dass es höfliche Formen für Bewegungsverben gibt und dann ist immer die Richtung des Bewegungsverbs nicht mehr klar. Also kommen und gehen ist dann das gleiche Verb. Und damit ist es halt nie so richtig klar, ob jetzt etwas erst in Gang kommt oder schon geht. Und das ist halt deshalb, also wenn man das dann so übersetzt, heißt es eben ja, es beginnt dort etwas. Aber es könnte auch sein, es geht voran.
Im Gegensatz zu der geschriebenen?
Genau. In der geschriebenen Sprache kann man das natürlich dann, also die ist dann verwendungsmäßig drastisch. Aber wenn halt der Regierungssprecher etwas erklärt hat, dann ist das in der Regel mündlich und dann muss man es halt interpretieren.
Das heißt, Interpretationssache und dann noch eine Übersetzungsprobleme möglicherweise. Das heißt, ihr geht jetzt von der Kernschmelze aus oder?
Ja, sicher. Also da ist mindestens in einem Fall eine Kernschmelze.
Vor allem, wenn sie sprechen von 1000 Millisievert pro Stunde.
Ja, ein Sievert, das ist erheblich.
Das ist ein Sievert und das ist erheblich. Also die tödliche Dosis, von der man immer so ausgeht, liegt im Bereich von zwei bis fünf. Und allein die Ausdrucksform 1000 Millisievert ist schon, also das liest man ein, zwei Mal, dann fasst man sich an den Kopf, sie wollen also nicht sagen, dass da irgendwie ein Sievert, sondern sie streuen dann noch dieses Milli ein, damit es trotz der 1000 noch ein bisschen weniger aussieht.
Naja, du musst auch denken, jetzt sind wir pro Zeit, also es sind 1000 Millisievert pro Stunde, also ein Sievert pro Stunde. Wenn ein Arbeiter da vier Stunden arbeitet, dann hat er halt die tödliche Dosis.
Genau, sie schicken sie da jetzt in so 15 Minuten Etappen rein und das ist halt eine statistische Angelegenheit, also kannst du auch nicht sagen, dass irgendjemand nach fünf Sievert definitiv und auf jeden Fall oder was auch immer, das ist halt eine statistische Sache und da überhaupt jemanden für 15 Minuten reinzuschicken, ja.
Ich hab da neulich einen schönen Spruch, auf Twitter hab ich das immer gelesen, ist eigentlich der beste Spruch, den ich nicht mal gehört habe, ist, wenn Statistiker dir sagt, dass ein Fluss durchschnittlich einen halben Meter tief ist, dann solltest du nicht durchgehen und ich glaube, das trifft das dann tatsächlich auch. Die ganzen Dinge, die da in Japan passieren, die wirken ja oft ein bisschen hilflos, weiter hergeholt, je nachdem, also irgendwie wir spannen jetzt planend über den Reaktor, wir werfen da mit Hubschraubern Wasser drüber. Ich frage mich aber, heute gab es auf Kryptom hochauflösende Fotos von diesem Reaktordingens. Da hat man das gesehen, an einem Gebäude sehr schön, da ist dieser riesige Reaktorblock, der quasi nur noch aus einem Skelett besteht, also dieses Gebäude, und da ist so ein kleiner Minilaster, der so einen kleinen Minischlauch da oben draufhält, und dann spritzt er so ein bisschen Wasser raus. Ist das eigentlich, sagen wir, also in Aktionismus gegossenes Neusprech? Also macht man das, weil man sich in der Sprache immer darauf bezieht, dass man jetzt noch was machen muss?
Also es gibt erstmal einen sprachlichen Aspekt, das wird dann von Krisenmanagement gesprochen. Aber natürlich ist das keine Krise, sondern eine Katastrophe. Also Krisenmanagement passt da natürlich nicht. Und dann ist aber klar, dass die Betreiberfirma und die Politiker natürlich zeigen wollen, wir tun was. Und dann wird eben irgendwas gemacht. Aber das hilft halt eigentlich nicht. Ich meine, das ist ja der Punkt, auch mit der Kernschmelze. Die Gerät, die beginnt, und dann ist sie nicht mehr zu stoppen. Denn es wird halt immer heißer und immer heißer. Und man müsste es halt plötzlich kühlen, kann es aber nicht kühlen. Also ist es nicht zu stoppen. Und ich meine, wenn das dann bei 2.000, 2.500 Grad angekommen ist, dann ist es mit dem Wasser, mit der Wasserkühlung nicht mehr.
Das Problem ist, dass es dann schon anfängt zu tropfen. Und genau das ist, was man irgendwie vermeiden wollte. Und das kann dann nicht ein bisschen anfangen. Das ist wie ein bisschen schwanger. Da ist dann halt die Situation erreicht, die man die ganze Zeit verhindern wollte.
So ist es einfach. Aber um das noch mal auf den Punkt zu bringen, stellt sich für mich dann so dar, weil die Politiker dieses Neusprech benutzen, von dem man Neusprech ist. Deswegen können sie quasi nicht zugeben, dass sie jetzt keinen Plan mehr haben. Und das hat dann tatsächlich reale Konsequenzen. Also in Deutschland ist es ja noch so, okay, das wird halt weiter betrieben. Glücklicherweise ist noch nichts passiert. Also uns ebensovorgehend auch nicht. Aber dort in Japan hat das halt die krassen Konsequenzen, dass dann Leute quasi verheizt werden.
Genau.
Aufgrund von Neusprech.
Na gut, das ist in Russland aber auch passiert.
Genau, das ist in Russland auch passiert. Aber weil du vorhin gesagt hast, die Politiker können nicht anders oder so. Man muss ja auch sehen, was hier im Vorhinein passiert. Es gibt ja keinen Katastrophenplan, der wirklich adäquat wäre, wo man wirklich vorher weiß, was man tun kann. Also das ist ein weiterer Grund, warum man die Kernkraftwerke nicht betreiben darf.
Das ist sozusagen ein auslegungsüberschreitender Störfall. Es ist quasi ein Störfall, der nicht vorgesehen ist und der überschreitet halt den Rahmen, für den das Ganze ausgelegt ist. Das ist das Neusprechwort für Gau.
Oder auch das mit dem Restrisiko, was du vorhin angesprochen hast. Das klingt wie so ein bisschen, naja, Restrisiko, Rest, ein kleiner Rest, ich sage es immer. Aber es ist, also erstmal ist ein Risiko immer ein Restrisiko, denn beim Risiko geht es immer um einen Rest. Und dann sieht man aber in diesem Fall, also normalerweise, also Risiko zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass man sich dagegen versichern kann. Weil Risiko immer, da weiß man, also so und so viel, so ist das, da müssen die Prämien halt so sein. Aber hier handelt es sich um etwas, wo man sich nicht gegenversichern kann. Also keine Versicherung würde das Restrisiko der AKWs...
Also es ist in der Tat de facto so, dass es keine Versicherung gibt, die das tut.
Ja, und damit ist es ja ein Risiko.
Da habe ich ja neulich was anderes gelesen. Und zwar ist es so, dass Kernkraftwerke in Deutschland wohl mit 250 Millionen versichert sind, sozusagen bei der Versicherung. Und die müssen aber versichert sein über 2, 5 Milliarden. Was sie dann gemacht haben ist, sie haben sich gegenseitig versichert. Also die Betreiber der verschiedenen Kernkraftwerke haben sich gegenseitig die Garantie gegeben. Also wenn dir jetzt was passiert, dann springen wir mit ein.
Aber das ist nicht das Restrisiko, was versichert ist. Das sind die übrigen Risiken.
Aber das Schöne ist, man kann dann sagen, das Kernkraftwerk ist versichert. Das ist doch eigentlich alles Mutter, oder?
Du hast so ein Batzen Geld, mit dem man dann spekulieren kann.
Ja, was mich gefragt hat, ist, was passiert, wenn zwei gleichzeitig, dann sind das ja schon 5 Milliarden. Ach so, stimmt, wie konnte ich das vergessen? Ja, das ist unwahrscheinlich vorgesehen. Wir haben jetzt sozusagen, vor allem über die erste Erklärung von Frau Merkel gesprochen. Gibt es jetzt über die Wochen, also irgendwie Herr Röttgen sagt ja ja, aber vielleicht nicht und ich habe es ja schon immer gesagt, aber eigentlich darf ich das nicht und so. Hast du noch irgendwelche Stilblüten beobachtet, die man jetzt noch erwähnen könnte?
Naja, also ich habe es doch vorhin schon gesagt, es gibt halt immer etwas, was wiederkehrt. Das ist eben die Sache mit der Tagesordnung. Das finde ich also sehr auffällig, dass immer noch dieses Bild von der Tagesordnung verwendet wird. Also egal, wer spricht, wird immer gleich von der Tagesordnung gesprochen. Das ist sehr auffällig.
Das Thema ist also nicht auf der Tagesordnung?
Nein, nein, nein. Also es gibt irgendwie eine Tagesordnung, die wir nicht genau kennen, aber soll wohl sein, dass man weitermacht mit den Kernkraftwerken. Und jetzt soll halt im Moment mal eben nicht zur Tagesordnung übergegangen werden, im Oratorium oder was auch immer. Aber es ist halt tatsächlich diese Idee der Tagesordnung, dass es eine Ordnung gibt, ein Ablauf der Dinge, der eben, also dieser Ablauf ist eben alternativlos. Jetzt macht man eine kurze Pause und dann geht es weiter im Takt. Und das ist eben das, was ich da so störend finde. Weil es ganz klar ausdrückt, dass hier niemand gewillt ist, eine Politik zu verändern. Also was anderes zu machen. Sondern es soll nur mal kurz pausiert werden und dann geht die Ordnung der Dinge halt weiter.
Und die Ordnung der Dinge ist ja, dass wir Atomkraftwerke haben.
Genau. Und haben sollen.
Ja, natürlich. Das ist ja auch abgesehen von ungesehenen. Also das ist schön. Gerade siehst du hier neben bei NT-V, da steht, Lage, Fukushima, unverändert schlecht. Das ist genau das, was in den Medien gerade passiert, zu sagen, weil die Aktivität 4.350 fach überhöht.
Ja, was ist denn das normale, wohin geht es denn? Also das ist kein absoluter, das ist irgendwie, das ist eine Aussage, mit der man nichts anfangen kann.
Ja, weil du gerade sagtest, neue Wendungen, was auffällt. Zum Beispiel wird jetzt immer gesagt, in den nächsten Monaten. Also erstmal wird uns dieses Unglück in Japan Millionen von Monaten beschäftigen. Die Halbwertzeit von Cesium ist nämlich relativ hoch. Und da kann man schon mal von 10.000 Jahren sprechen. Also diese Monate. Und dann wird es mit den nächsten Monaten ja auch immer auf Deutschland bezogen. Aber wenn wir denken, das Moratorium hat ja schon begonnen. Das heißt, der erste Monat ist irgendwie halb rum. Also es sind ja jetzt nicht die nächsten Monate, sondern muss ja dann in anderthalb Monaten ist das Moratorium vorbei. Das heißt, man muss im nächsten Monat ja schon eine Entscheidung haben.
Ja, aber das bedeutet, wir deutschen wieder total vorne. Das bedeutet nämlich, unser Moratorium und die Stresstests sind schneller fertig, als sie die Katastrophe in Japan unter Kontrolle. Das ist doch großartig. Kommen wir noch mal zurück zu den Informationsquellen, aus denen man sich bedienen kann. Da hat Manu zu angerufen, die weiß ich gar nicht eine Frage dazu hat oder welche nennen will. Hallo Manu. Ach ja, wie man es macht, macht man es falsch. Willst du uns jetzt deine Informationsquellen präsentieren?
Ja, wenn ihr das möchtet, kann ich das auch tun. Ich habe relativ schnell festgestellt, dass das, was in den Mainstream-Medien läuft, erstens keinen Sinn ergibt, zweitens scheinbar auch fachlich nicht ganz korrekt war. Daraufhin habe ich angefangen im Netz natürlich nach Alternativen zu suchen, mich auch erst mal allgemein zu Störfall zu informieren, weil das war ja doch etwas, das man vorher nicht so richtig auf dem Zettel hatte. Und habe dann recht schnell festgestellt, dass es auch im Netz nicht ganz einfach ist, an verlässliche Quellen zu kommen. Habe dann aber festgestellt, dass eben doch Seiten, gerade aus japanischer Ebene, vorhanden sind, auf denen man zumindest auf handfeste Messwerte zurückgreifen muss, kann, was natürlich zur Folge hat, dass man sich mit der ganzen Materie doch etwas intensiver beschäftigen muss. Dabei habe ich festgestellt, dass es fantastische Blogs am Internet gibt, wo auch Leute, die sich mit der Materie deutlich beschäftigt haben, bzw. sich auch studieren, Informationen auf einer sehr einfachen Ebene zu verfügen stellen, so dass man auch als Laie in der Lage ist, sie doch relativ schnell zu verstehen und dahinter zu steigen, was die Messwerte zu bedeuten haben.
Jetzt muss ich kurz zu der Frage, du meinst Seiten aus Japan, hast du englischsprachige Seiten oder sprichst du japanisch?
Nein, englischsprachig. Japanisch gehört nicht zu meinen Repertoireseiten. Auf Deutsch gibt es meines Wissens nur eine, die die Informationen entsprechend auch für Laien aufbereitet. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich bei euch mit URLs durch die Gegend werfen soll darf.
Na ja, das wird jetzt glaube ich hier über das Radio zu weit führen. Du kannst aber gerne ins Wiki zur Sendung gehen oder der Chaosradio.de dort einfach reinwerfen. Dann können nämlich alle anderen auch klicken. Das wäre ganz praktisch.
Hervorragend, wäre ich nachher probieren. Wobei ich eine gerne loswerden würde, das wäre nämlich der Physikblock EU, weil eben das die Jungs sind, die doch in der Lage sind, auch der breiten Masse und dem breiten interessierten Bevölkerung eben die Informationen so zur Verfügung zu stellen, dass man sie auch versteht und vor allen Dingen hat sich dort eine Kultur entwickelt, die sehr technisch und doch verständlich über die Vorgänge diskutiert, wo man dann auch sehr schnell feststellen muss, dass selbst die Informationen, die man aus den Medien oder aus öffentlicher japanischer Seite bekommt, eben doch mangelhaft bis fehlerhaft sind oder eben nur die halbe Wahrheit darstellt.
Das finde ich aber ganz spannend von wegen der Informationsbeschaffung. An welchem Punkt machst du fest, dass Leute, die zwar vom Fach sind, aber hier in Deutschland sitzen, zuverlässigere Informationen haben als die von vor Ort?
Ich gehe aber nicht von zuverlässigeren Informationen aus, sondern einfach von der von der Interpretation der vorhandenen Misswerte, dass man dann schon sagen kann, also wenn wir feststellen, wir haben einen Reaktor irgendwie 400 Grad plus zweimal Druck, kann der nicht dicht sein, weil eben bei 400 Grad und ein bisschen Wasser eben deutlich höherer Druck existieren müsste. Das würde vermutlich dem normalen Nutzer nicht auffallen, aber eben Leute, die sich mit der Materie intensiv beschäftigen, stellen dann eben sowas auch ganz schnell fest und können dann daraus auch Rückschlüsse auf die Technik führen beziehungsweise in den Quellen, wo ich mich jetzt bewegt habe, war es elementar wichtig, dass die Leute eben Kenntnis von Reaktorsicherheit und auch von dem Aufbau von diversen Reaktoren hatten, so dass die Informationen, die zu bekommen waren, ganz anders deuten konnten, als sie in der Presse oder im Fernsehen publiziert wurden.
Würdest du sagen, die Massenmedien würdest du gar nicht mehr benutzen für solche Sachen?
Ich kann sogar sagen, ich verzichte seit zwei Wochen komplett auf Informationen aus den Massenmedien, weil ich mich dann in einer Regel darüber geärgert habe, dass dort entweder die halbe Wahrheit oder teilweise auch Messwerte deutlich verfeilscht dargestellt werden. Also wir haben den letzten Tagen da ganz deutlich beobachten können, dass Milli, Mycro und Mega irgendwie bunt durcheinander gewürfelt wurden, aber nichts mehr mit den Messwerten zu tun hatten, wenn man sie dann auch in den Massenmedien mal veröffentlicht hat. Das war teilweise schockierend.
Würdest du sagen, das finde ich immer eine spannende Frage, wenn es um diese Diskussion geht, weil die Massenmedien haben immer das Problem, sie dürfen die Informationen erst anbringen, wenn sie sie entweder selber verifiziert haben oder unter Angabe der Quelle. Würdest du es denn als adäquat empfinden, wenn Massenmedien anfangen zu sagen, wir haben mir dieses Blog gelesen, guckt euch das mal an, das klingt ganz gut, wir können natürlich auch nicht so genau verifizieren, ob das wahr ist.
Nein, ich will nicht, dass ich die Massenmedien auf den Blog beziehe, der war halt nur dadurch dazu gut, um mir die Messwerte, die ich halt von offizieller Stelle, zum Beispiel von einer japanischen Atom- und Industrieaufsicht.
Also du meinst, die Massenmedien sollen einfach mal ordentlich erarbeiten, weil sie so viel geschlammt haben?
Ja, nicht geschlammt.
Es geht dort einfach...
In den letzten Tagen hat man ganz deutlich gemerkt, dass sich jeder, der sich Experte auf die Fahnen geschrieben hat, sich zu dem Thema äußern durfte, hat man drei Experten gehört, hat man fünf verschiedene Meinungen. Und das führte teilweise meiner Meinung nach auch sehr zur Verunsicherung in der Bevölkerung. Also ich bin relativ später zugekommen, ich habe davon erst erfahren, als in den Massenmedien halt die Bilder von einer Explosion vom Block 1 liefen und war dann relativ geschockt, weil ich vorher davon ausgeknüpft bin, dass wir solche Bilder nach Tschernobyl nie wieder sehen werden, was sich ja nun als äußerst unwahr herausgestellt hat. Und habe dann unmittelbar versucht, verlässliche Informationen zu bekommen, habe festgestellt, dass halt auf den üblichen privaten Nachrichtensendern irgendwie eine Informationsveranstaltung im Stundenrhythmus läuft, die ja aufgrund der meinen Informationen logischerweise auch keine neuen Erkenntnisse bringen konnte. Und habe dann aber bei der Suche nach, wie komme ich schneller an Informationen, auch ganz schnell festgestellt, dass dort viele Angaben einfach falsch sind.
Wir machen jetzt mal Folgendes, wir nehmen es mal dem Matthias dazu, der hat nämlich eine technische Frage und vielleicht kannst du ihm ja mit einer Belesenheit über die ganzen Quellen weiterhelfen. Matthias, hallo. Tach?
Ja, hallo.
Du hast eine technische Frage.
Ja, und zwar, ich habe jetzt die Sendung gerade ein bisschen verfolgt und ich überlege schon lange, seit das jetzt war, mit dieser Katastrophe, weiß einer von euch, ob das irgendwie möglich ist, radioaktive Strahlung in irgendeiner Art und Weise sichtbar zu machen, also so, als wenn man zum Beispiel mit einer Infrarotbildkamera, ja, Darme-Strahlung sichtbar machen kann, ob das irgendwie möglich ist. Weil das gefährlich ist, finde ich, ist ja daran, dass das einfach nicht so unsichtbar ist. Man weiß eben nie, wo es ist. Man kann es nur messen mit einem Geigerzähler oder sich auf irgendwelche Werte verlassen, aber im Prinzip nicht irgendwie visualisieren, so gerade welche Strahlung.
Interessante Frage, habe ich ehrlich gesagt keinen Plan von, von euch jemand?
Aber Geigerzähler sind doch schon mal gar nicht so schlecht. Also ich finde, dieses Ticken ist schon sehr deutlich.
Naja, also… Ja, in einer Nebelkammer zum Beispiel kann man das nicht, weil das ist ja nicht so richtig viel, was da an, also aus so einer Lampe kommen jetzt wahrscheinlich mehr Vertun als Gamma-Strahler an. Also ich bin auch nicht Physiker, um das halt so zu sagen, aber bis auf eine Nebelkammer kann ich mir dort nicht groß was vorstellen.
Was macht eine Nebelkammer?
Das ist im Prinzip ein Gerät, wo man radioaktive Teilchen oder das, was da imitiert wurde, nachvollziehen kann. Da sieht man dann halt so eine Nebelspur und sieht auch, ob das jetzt, wenn da noch ein Feld zu angelegt ist, ein Gamma-Strahlung oder ein Alpha-Teilchen ist. Das ist ein Heliumkern, das ist ja relativ schwer und im Feld, einfach mal die ewikipedia.org/wiki/neokammer klicken.
Der Chat unter Chaosradio auf freenet.net sagt ja auch, dass man auch zum Beispiel auf Film, auf Fotofilm die Radioaktivität sehen kann.
Das sieht man an den Chernobyl Dokus.
Genau, das sieht man sehr schön. Der Punkt ist natürlich, wenn man das auf dem Film hat, ist es eigentlich schon zu spät. Diese Gamma-Strahlen sind halt sehr schnell und dann ist man schon erreicht worden von denen. Durch Sichtbarmachung oder auch durch Hörbarmachung, Geigerzähler, hat man immer nur so eine relativ späte Warnung davor.
Das funktioniert übrigens auch mit Digitalkameras ganz gut. Auch die CCD-Ships oder CMOS-Ships reagieren sehr wohl auf Gamma-Strahlung.
Wie äußert sich das dann? Durch massives Bildrauschen. Wenn die Kamera anfängt zu rauschen, dann sollte man vielleicht schneller das Weite suchen.
Im Moment sind ja alle Geigerzähler ausverkauft, aber sonst ist das schon eine gute Anschaffung. Ich habe mir mal einen ausgeliehen von einem Nerd. Im Chaos Computer Club laufen ja viele Leute mit solchen Equipment um.
Du meinst also, egal ob gerade irgendwo was explodiert ist oder nicht?
Ja, es ist immer ganz gut, so etwas zu haben. Ich habe also bei mir in der Wohnung schon mal alles ausgemessen. Allerdings vor dem Unlück. Aber ich fand das sehr interessant.
Eine Banane zu halten. Einer der lustigsten Wikipedia-Artikel, den ich mir in dem Zusammenhang durchgelesen habe, war die Banane-Equivalentdosis.
Okay, und was ist die Banane? Mann, Leute, lasst doch nicht alles aus der Nase ziehen. Was ist denn die Banane-Equivalentdosis?
Die beruht darauf, dass man in Tokio einen Stahlenwert festgestellt hat, der meines Wissens irgendwo bei 0, 01 sieben Mikrosievert pro Stunde lag. Und dann hat sich ein Atomphysiker hingesetzt und hat gesagt, lasst auf, Jungs, wenn wir uns eine Banane angucken, eine Banane enthält relativ viel Karium. Karium kommt in seiner natürlichen Form auch im Isotrop Karium-40 vor Karium-40 strahlt. Wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht, wir messen mal eine Banane aus, stellt man relativ schnell fest, dass wenn man jede Stunde eine Banane ist, hat man in etwa dieselbe Dosis aufgenommen, als hätte man sich in Tokio aufgehalten. Die Betreiber des Physik-Blocks weisen darauf hin, dass der Verzehr einer Banane mit Sicherheit gesundheitsschädlich ist, allerdings nicht auf die Strahlung zurückzuführen, sondern auf die einseitige Annäherung.
Okay, da wird also auch ein bisschen von der Panikmache runtergekommen. Das finde ich ja immer ganz schwierig, auch bei diesem ganzen Thema, dass man so schnell auf die, ich will nicht sagen die falsche Seite, aber diese Gradwanderung zwischen jetzt nicht Panik machen, aber trotzdem immer das Auge offen halten und sich nicht eindurlen lassen. Von sich aus Beschreibung ist wirklich sehr schwierig. Wie macht ihr das denn eigentlich? Fühlt ihr euch hier sicher, Man und Matthias?
Ja, also ich mich momentan schon eben, weil ich mich mit der Materie deutlich beschäftigt habe und der Fressen überzeugt bin, dass bei uns die Strahlung nicht so hoch werden wird, auch wenn der Wind dringendstig steht, als dass ich jetzt hier in akuter Gefahr wäre. Was unsere Regierung angeht, ob ich mich da sicher fühlen kann, was da an Informationen rausgeht, halte ich noch für fraglich.
Das ist eine andere Frage in der Tat. Matthias, wie sieht es bei dir aus?
Ja, also kann ich mich eigentlich auch nur so anschließen. Ich glaube jetzt auch nicht, dass die Strahlung direkt bis hierhin kommt. Allerdings, die indirekten Auswirkungen der Katastrophe können natürlich schon verheerender werden. Also wenn man auch überlegt, was das eventuell für Auswirkungen auf die Finanzmärkte, auf die Börsen etc. haben könnte. Weil ja Japan doch auch schon eine relativ große Volkswirtschaft ist. Das macht mir persönlich auch schon ein paar Sorgen, weil in der Geschichte einige Wirtschaftskrisen oder einige große Krisen passiert.
Was machen wir da jetzt weniger um die Finanzmärkte als auch um dieses Land? Einfache Sorgen, weil die hatten halt nicht nur diese AKW-Geschichte, sondern auch ein Erdbeben und ein Tsunami, wo irgendwie 100.000 Leute, 100.000 Leute obdachlos geworden sind. Und zum anderen ist Japan jetzt nicht so furchtbar groß. Also das Wetter in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten und weitere Strahlenemissionen oder Material, was da rauskommt, das kann da noch ganz schnell ganz, ganz böse werden, weil so viel Land ist, dass nicht was da verstrahlt werden kann und muss, damit man keinen Spaß mehr hat in dem Land. Also das hat schon durchaus das Potenzial, so ein Staat wie Japan deutlich, ich werde jetzt nicht sagen, von der Landkarte zu wischen, aber eine große Teile unbewohnbar zu machen.
Ja, und das hat natürlich wirklich auch ganz schwere Folgen. Einmal natürlich in Japan, da kann man sagen, ich bin so weit weg, aber ich meine, wir sind natürlich eine Welt. Und wenn da alles zusammenbricht und viele Menschen leiden, hat das natürlich auch dann weitere Auswirkungen.
Düstere Aussichten kann man sagen. Und dazu kommt noch, dass hier in Deutschland auch nicht so ganz klar ist, was mit unseren Atomkraftwerken wird. Wir werden gleich nochmal ein bisschen weiter in die Zukunft gucken. Jetzt haben wir gleich noch ein kleines Stückchen Musik, dann Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und dann weiter mit der letzten halben Stunde Chaosradio.
So gleich.
Und eine halbe haben wir noch hier beim Chaosradio am letzten Donnerstag im Monat. Es geht heute um Informationsverwaltung, Beschaffung und Analyse im Zeitalter von Atomunglücken. Wir haben schon reichherzig darüber gesprochen, wie man als Nerd helfen kann mit dem Projekt Geigercrow zum Beispiel und was die Politiker und so erzählen und wie man da rumkommt und was man davon ernst nehmen kann und was nicht. Ihr seid auch in der letzten halben Stunde noch aufgerufen, anzurufen und dann 0331 70 97 110 und Maha und Nibbler sind hier zu Gast. Und Maha ist ja ein Neusprechexperte und wir können jetzt mal noch zum Schluss zu den ganz grundlegenden Dingen kommen, nämlich du beschäftigst dich auch mit einzelnen Worten, die mit dem Thema zu tun haben und es gibt das schöne mich an einem Müsli Riegel erinnernden frischen vor Kraft trotz den Begriff Kernkraft.
Das wollen wir auch noch in unserem Neusprechblog, also neusprech.org, auseinandernehmen. Das Problem ist halt nur, dass wir dazu recherchieren müssen in Zeiten, wo das alles im Internet noch nicht so richtig dokumentiert ist. Und das ist immer so anstrengend. Also wenn jemand was weiß, bitte gebt uns die Information. Also es fällt halt auf, dass man in älteren Texten Atomenergie findet, dann Atomkraft und plötzlich Kernkraft. Und wenn man jetzt tatsächlich, der eine oder andere erinnert sich noch, da gab es diese Kampagne CO2, also gegen CO2, und auf den Plakaten der Energiebetreiber stand dann auch immer Kernkraft und nicht Atomkraft. Also Atomkraft war schon negativ besetzt, weil man das kannte vom Aufkleber Atomkraft, nein danke, dann wurde Kernkraft besagt. Und eben ganz früher eben Atomenergie. Also von der Atomenergie ist man zu Atomkraft gekommen, Kraft klingt sehr positiv, und dann Kernkraft statt Atomkraft. Aber eigentlich passt Kernkraft gar nicht, denn bei der Kernkraft, mit der Kernkraft, sagen wir eigentlich die Kräfte, die im Kern den Kern zusammenhalten. Und ja, was man hier gewinnt, ist ja Energie, die entsteht beim Zerfall des Kerns. Also es passt nicht so ganz von der Beschreibung. Jetzt tickt hier der Geigerzimmer.
Sind wir schon verstrahlt, oder?
Aha, gut, also man sieht, ein Wort ist irgendwann unangenehm geworden wegen Atomkraft und Erdanke, also wird was anderes gesagt, was noch schöner klingt. Kernkraft erinnert auch gar nicht mehr an Atom. Ähnlich auch im Englischen, da wird dann von Nuclear gesprochen. Nuclear ist eben auch nicht Atomic oder so. Nach der Atomic Bomb kommt dann eben der Nuclear Power.
Jetzt ist ja davon auszugehen, dass auch der Begriff Kernkraft dann sozusagen irgendwann auf diesen Aufklärung auftaucht, wo ein Danken nach dazu drauf steht. Vielleicht können wir jetzt gleich noch mal ein neues Wort entwickeln, ein positives Wort für diese Energien.
Ein positives Wort nach der Kernkraft.
Dein Tipp als Linguist, was kommt?
Man sieht es schon. Man sieht im Deutschen plötzlich das Adjektiv Nuklear. Das war nicht gebräuchlich in dem Zusammenhang.
Nuklearenergie.
Nuklearenergie, genau.
Eine Renaissance des Energieworts und dann mit Nuklear davor.
Nuklear, genau.
So ein bisschen wissenschaftlich quasi.
Das ist die Malenwörter von Kern, vom Atomkern.
Aber Kernkraft klingt so ein bisschen nach Bio. Was ist denn so? Dinkelkern. Kernkraft, super. Wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit auch schon darüber gesprochen, was denn eigentlich zuverlässige Informationsquellen sind heutzutage. Also einerseits um an die Daten zu kommen, was ist in Japan eigentlich wirklich los, was nicht wirklich einfach ist. Und andererseits auch um mal rauszufinden, was in Deutschland so abgeht. Was ist denn eure Empfehlung da? Also wir haben jetzt die Hörer angerufen und gesagt, so Twitter hat sie überraschenderweise, also für die Hörer überraschenderweise, sind an manchen Stellen auch gut informiert. Und es gibt einen Blog zum Beispiel, wurde gesagt, wo man die Hintergründe gut verstehen konnte. Und was zeichnet denn für euch jetzt heute in diesem Bereich eine zuverlässige Informationsquelle aus? Und wo findet man die?
Naja, also ich glaube, ich glaube, dass mit Twitter das gar nicht so schlecht ist. Denn bei Twitter wird eben doch, man hört immer von Journalisten, ja, aber das ist da alles, muss erst nachgeprüft werden und so.
Entschuldigung, ich möchte nicht über einen Kamm geschoren werden.
Ja, wir erinnern uns da an dieses Gespräch mit dem Regierungssprecher, wo der Regierungssprecher den Journalisten erzählt, was Twitter ist und die sagen immer, ja, aber das ist doch nicht sicher und naja, das geht doch nicht. Ja, aber das Interessante bei Twitter ist schon, dass die Information dann interessant wird, wenn die richtigen Leute, denen man eben folgt, von denen man Meinung an was hält, das dann eben auch retweeten. Und einer kann sich immer mal ehren, aber wenn dann das doch viele tun, ja, dann kann ich schon dem Ganzen vielleicht vertrauen, was da kommt.
Das ist in der Tat so die kleine Variante von dem, was ich auch empfehlen würde, sich einfach nicht nur aus Rennerquelle zu informieren, sondern aus verschiedenen Quellen und sich dann zu den Quellen auch immer angucken, wie ist die Motivation. Gerade was Blockbeiträge zu dem Thema angeht, findet man da durchaus Gehaltvolle, wo man irgendwie das Gefühl hat, von Physikern oder von fachlicher Stelle informiert zu werden. Aber die sind alle auch in einer gewissen Art und Weise gefärbt. Also es gibt Physiker, die sagen, ich erkläre das mit der Nuklearenergie. Das ist ganz sicher und ganz hm, deswegen und deswegen. Und gerade bei so einem Thema, wo es eben unterschiedliche Meinungen darüber geht, ist das halt alles immer so ein bisschen gefärbt. Also da ist wirklich die Vielfalt, sich aus mehreren Quellen zu informieren und sich zu gucken, wer hat das geschrieben, welches Interesse könnte er da haben und dann eben sich seine eigene Meinung daraus zu bilden.
Das ist natürlich richtig. Auf jeden Fall sollte man sich aus verschiedenen Quellen informieren, denn es ist einfach so, es gibt nicht die eine richtige Wahrheit. Es gibt immer viele Wahrheiten und von daher muss man eben auch tatsächlich mehrere Quellen sich anschauen. Also ich glaube, das ist wirklich ganz, ganz wichtig. Natürlich ist es so, dass man sicherlich auch, ja, sich Hintergrundwissen beschaffen kann. Das ist ja inzwischen auch ganz leicht, da kann man in die Wikipedia schauen, die wir zwar auch manchmal schlecht geredet, aber immerhin. Also das ist ein Zugang, da gibt es dann weitere Links und was da da so an Links ist, kann man sich ja dann anschauen und dann kommt man sehr schnell schon zu tiefen Einsichten.
Ich, also da werde ja das Gefühl nicht los, dass ihr, also auch häufiger hier in der Sendung sagt, dass man selber also aktiv werden muss.
Ja, man muss immer selber aktiv werden, auch wenn man Informationen haben will. Also das ist ja eben gerade der Ansatz, man darf sich nicht einfach bescheiden lassen von, es wurde ja vorhin schon gesagt, von den Massenmedien, man muss eben sich die Information holen. Das kann man natürlich auch auf den Webseiten der Tagesschau und so weiter, ist auch klar, ZDF, Mediathek und Arte, Dokus und sonst was. Aber man muss eben selber gucken und eben genauer hingucken und sich eben die Information holen. Ich glaube, das ist genau das, was man machen muss. Man muss selber aktiv werden und sich was holen und nicht einfach sich berieseln lassen.
Da würde ich jetzt aber gerne zum Schluss tatsächlich, also jetzt auf diesen Fall hier sozusagen bezogen mal gerne wissen, wo ihr euch sozusagen hauptsächlich informiert habt. Ich würde mal einen Anfang machen. Ich habe irgendwann gefunden eine deutsche Seite, die für mich ziemlich gut funktioniert hat. Das sind die Anti-Atom-Piraten. Die sind natürlich also politisch klar gefärbt. Die haben es aber wirklich sehr gut drauf gehabt, eine Mischung aus Informationen von Medien zu übernehmen. Die haben die Nachrichtenticker von Reuters im Auge gehabt und auch sozusagen so kleine Sachen von von nebenher zu sagen. Und die haben immer auch die Informationen, die unbestätigt waren, haben sich dann meistens als sozusagen wahr oder zumindest in der Richtung richtig herausgestellt. Das fand ich sehr gut. Dann fand ich sehr gut die Nachrichtangentur Reuters hat einen Feed, das fand ich ganz großartig, weil das das erste Mal gesehen habe bei einem großen Medium. Die haben also einen Feed, wo sie ihre eigenen Meldungen raus tun zu dem Thema, zu Fukushima, ein Live-Feed, der sich auch automatisch aktualisiert. Und die kennzeichnen ihre eigenen Meldungen. Die nehmen aber tatsächlich nach einer Prüfung auch User-Kommentare auf. Das heißt, da findet man natürlich nicht alles, aber das ist sozusagen eine sehr breite Masse und von einem Dienst, der auch sozusagen, also wo man weiß, der ist darauf angewiesen, dass er jetzt nicht irgendwie den größten Scheiß produziert. Und für Hintergrundberichte habe ich immer gerne den Guardian gelesen, die sind immer sehr gut. Da muss man natürlich Englisch können, also es gilt bei Reuters auch, aber das sind so für mich die drei Quellen eigentlich gewesen in den letzten Wochen, wo ich mich am besten informiert gefühlt habe.
Würde ich dir zustimmen. Ich würde auf jeden Fall aber noch ergänzen, Zeit Online. Zeit Online hat gerade am Anfang der Katastrophe, haben die ja nachts durchgemacht und waren der einzige deutschsprachige Ticker, natürlich dann Twitter, also Twicker kann man das so gleich nennen. Und da wurde wirklich also kontinuierlich informiert und auch auf, also mit wirklich guten Links. Also das hat mich auch sehr überzeugt. Ich hab dann ja sogar getwittert, dass offenbar Zeit Online jetzt das Nachrichtenmonopol in Deutschland übernommen hat. Von der Tagesschau kam nichts mehr, es war halb vier Uhr morgens, da haben die da andere Dinge zu tun gehabt, ich weiß nicht was. Aber bei Zeit Online ging es halt durch und das hat mich schon sehr überzeugt.
Ja, Zeit Online hat jetzt auch das Weblog Netzpolitik, also die ab morgen so eine Testphase übernommen. Übernommen, ja.
Zeitgleich zum neuen Design. Dazu aber vielleicht später mehr, was hast du denn, wo hast du dich denn informiert?
In der Tat auch diesen, das ist immer so das Problem, man hätte gerne halt sowas wie einen Feed, in dem man informiert wird über das, was passiert, da war in der Tat Reuters mit am, teilweise auch flottesten. Dann guckt man halt, man sucht dann auch nach einzelnen Begriffen, also man liest dann irgendwelche Sachverhalte und da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, kann ich mich nicht mehr an die einzelnen Seiten erinnern, aber das ging dann halt wirklich in die Tiefe, dass man sich anguckt, okay, der und der Sachverhalt, das lese ich jetzt da zwar, aber wie ist denn das wirklich? Dann verliert man sich auf den Seiten über die technischen Themen, den technischen Hintergrund von sowas.
Gibt es denn sowas sozusagen noch über die Wikipedia hinaus? Ich weiß, es ist schwierig, das jetzt kurz und knapp zu sagen und auch festzulegen, aber so ein Leitfaden für, wie unterscheide ich denn eigentlich eine Seite, eine Seite, die jetzt Informationen bietet, denen ich zumindest zum Teil trauen kann, von einer, die nur Blödsinn schreibt. Also was sind da eure Kriterien? Mal jetzt von Viagra-Werbung abgesehen.
Gegenverifizieren. Wenn da Dinge berichtet werden, werden die Berichte von anderer Seite, die nicht auch von dieser Quelle abgeschrieben haben, gestützt. Dann, welches Interesse besteht, also wer betreibt diese Informationsquelle und hat der eventuell oder die Interesse daran, die Information gefärbt darzustellen und ganz einfach eine Pausibilitätsprüfung und eben nach dem Motiv fragen.
Wir sind schon wieder bei selber nachdenken.
Na ja, also wenn man nicht so viel selber nachdenken will, kann man auch, das ist zwar immer gefährlich, aber kann man auch immer gucken, wer verlinkt denn noch auf die Seite. Das ist schon sehr aufschlussreich und da kann man sehr schnell wissen, also da kriegt man sehr schnell eine grobe Ahnung dafür, ob das seriös oder nicht seriös ist.
Jetzt würde ich zum, also fast zum Schluss, der ganze ist noch nicht, will noch zu einer kleinen Anekdote kommen, die ich sehr witzig fand. In Nibbler, du hast ja erzählt, dass du während deiner Arbeit für Geigercloud auch mit dem Hacker Space in Tokio Kontakt hattest.
Ja, die haben, das war auch so die Zielgruppe, die ich im Hinterkopf hatte, als ich mir überlegt habe, ja, den Crowd-Teil. Japan ist ein unglaublich technologieverliebtes Land, um da mal so ein Vorurteil zu transportieren. Und es muss da einfach Leute geben, die selbst an so Geräten bauen oder mit so Geräten Spaß haben, die eben sich mit dieser Radioaktivität in der einen oder anderen Form messtechnisch auseinandersetzen. Und der Hacker Space in Japan, die haben relativ früh schon daran gearbeitet, zum einen für die Leute, die davon betroffen sind, von dem Erdbeben und der Wohnungsproblematik, dass sie halt irgendwie jetzt kein Dach mehr über den Kopf haben, die haben Solarlampen gebaut, also Lampen, die sich tagsüber über Solarenergie aufladen und dann nachts eben über LEDs Licht abgeben. Wir haben da eine nach der anderen gelötet und verteilt und zum anderen auch einen Geigerzeller Bau-Workshop. Da waren sie auch noch nicht die einzigen im Internet, also es gibt eine ganze Handvoll Leute, die eben mit Mikrocontrollern selbst Mess-Equipment gebaut haben. Wir haben auch im CCCB jemanden, der Dexter hat da gebastelt, da habe ich den Link später. Ja, also das war ein relativ spannender Kontakt, weil die halt wirklich gesagt haben, ja, wir bauen da welche und werden das auch in Tokio verteilen. Also Tokio wird wahrscheinlich mit Abstand die engste Sensordichte haben, weil da eben eine ganze Handvoll Nerds sitzen, die, ich würde jetzt nicht sagen Spaß dran haben, aber die, ja, also die könnte man selbst bauen.
Das, wo ich tatsächlich ein bisschen lächeln musste, ist als so die Prioritätenliste irgendwie, also die man irgendwie schickt uns. Wie war das nochmal, die Top 3?
Wir arbeiten an Doppelpunkt Lampen, mobilen Handyladegeräten und Essensaufwärmungsapparaten. Also die Reihenfolge Licht, Kommunikationsinfrastruktur, Essen fand ich großartig.
Jetzt haben wir viel darüber geredet, was war und wie man damit klarkommen kann. Was sind denn eure Aussichten für, was wird jetzt passieren? Also würde mich ja quasi vor allem hier in Deutschland interessieren. Also wenn man dir so zuhört, denkt man ja so, okay, also eigentlich pasen die Politiker jetzt nur und es wird sich nichts ändern, also genau gar nichts. Ich habe ja tatsächlich manchmal noch die Hoffnung, vielleicht rocken wir ja doch irgendwie was.
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass das passieren kann, nur das wird dann eben passieren, so wie es eigentlich abzusehen ist, dass eben der, es wird ja immer von dem Konsens gesprochen, gerade der Röttgen hat jetzt von dem Konsens gesprochen, Konsens, also alle müssen wieder zu einem Konsens kommen bei Atomkraft und das wird halt sehr schwierig sein. Also ich glaube, es wird tatsächlich dann nochmal richtig Auseinandersetzungen geben mit großen Demonstrationen und so weiter und ich hoffe, dass auf diese Weise dann genug Druck aufgebaut wird, sodass es eben nicht so weitergehen kann. Richtig, das wird zu zeigen, dass die Tagesordnung mal endgültig abgesetzt wird.
Ja, dass das Teil der Tagesordnung wird, dass man sich damit auseinandersetzen muss, wie man das Problem eben löst.
Aber glaubt ihr wirklich, dass da in Deutschland Interesse dran besteht, ernsthaftes?
Seitens der Bevölkerung auf jeden Fall, wenn man sich die Demo angeschaut hat.
Doch, ich glaube auch. Also ich glaube, nach Tjernobyl ist es schon fast ungekippt. Und ja, da war die Welt aber noch anders. Da gab es halt noch den Ost-West-Konflikt in allen seinen Vorhangen und was weiß ich. Und dann waren die anderen immer die Schlechten, kann bei uns nicht passieren. Und so denke das ist jetzt anders. Und ich denke, es wird jetzt wirklich doch sehr viel stärker eben ein Widerspruch kommen. Aus der Bevölkerung kein Konsens.
Je nachdem, was man davon hält, bleibt zu hoffen, möchte ich an dieser Stelle sagen. So, so viel zur Atomkraft. Ich würde jetzt noch ein kurzes Stück Musik machen, dann reden wir noch mal. Genau, ich wollte gerade dazu kommen. Ich würde sagen, wir schließen jetzt das Thema ab, Atomkraft, machen ein kurzes Stück Musik, machen dann Werbung. Und danach geht es hier mit den Dingen weiter, die sonst noch so passieren. Wir sind gleich wieder da. Das ist auch Creative Commons Musik, sowas gibt es auch im Chaosradio. Bleiben uns nur noch wenige Minuten. Wir kommen jetzt zum Teil der Werbung. Als erstes muss da natürlich gesagt werden. Chaosradio gibt es auch als Podcast, natürlich auf Fritzsee, natürlich aber auch auf chaosradio.de gibt es auch einen Blog. Da könnt ihr noch mal kommentieren, wenn ihr irgendwie Anmerkungen noch habt zur Sendung, wenn ihr andere Dinge wollt oder genauso haben wollt oder wie auch immer. Sagt es uns dort, weil wenn ihr nichts sagt, dürft ihr nicht beschweren. So einfach ist das nämlich. Außerdem gibt es noch Veranstaltungshinweise.
Genau, also jetzt am Freitag um 18 Uhr in Bielefeld, ja wirklich in Bielefeld, Komm an! finden die Verleihung der Big Brother Awards statt. In der, wie heißt das da? Na ist auch egal. Also in diesem, wo das immer stattfindet. Und ja, da sind natürlich alle willkommen, vor allen Dingen, wer aus der Nähe von Bielefeld ist und auch weiter anreisen will. Ja, in der Ravensberger Spinnerei, gut. Also da lag ich gar nicht so schlecht bei den Spinnereien.
Weiß man eigentlich schon so? Irgendwie hat man schon so Gerüchte gehört, wer hier irgendwie erfolgreicher Kandidat möglicherweise ist.
Ja, es ist wohl auch diesmal, also man darf ja nichts verraten, es ist wohl auch diesmal ein Preisträger, also ein Preisträger, ein Vertreter eines großen Konzerns wird kommen. Oh! Wahrscheinlich hatten die sich nicht richtig in Form von jetzt aus. Das dürfte also spannend werden und wir werden auch ein bisschen über Neusprechen dort.
Wirst du auch da sein?
Ich werde auch da sein.
Ah, sehr schön.
Ja, direkt von hier nach Bielefeld. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das finden werde.
Ja, hoffentlich kommst du wieder zurück.
Ja, das ist der Paralleluniversum. Da gibts glaube ich ein Wurmloch.
Das ist also auch einer von ihnen.
Ja, im Sommer gibt es auch noch was.
Genau, Chaos Communication Camp 2011 in Finofort bei Berlin. Das ist so ein alter Flugplatz. Das ist total kuschelig da. Fünf Tage mit den Hackern auf dem Feld. Gibt Internet, habe ich gehört. Da ist die Faser schon klar gemacht worden.
Ab Tag eins oder?
Bestimmt.
Okay, wenn es losgeht, geht es durch den Wald.
Also, wird auf jeden Fall hübsch werden, vom 10. bis zum 14. August.
Und was passiert da, außer, dass da gezeltet und gewählernd wird?
Da wird gezeltet, gewählernd, ausgetauscht und es gibt Vorträge. Wenn man sich die angucken möchte, kann man sich natürlich auch gestreamt angucken, aber hinkommen ist immer schick. Ich meine, wann kann man schon mal mit einer vierstelligen Anzahl von Hackern auf einem ehemaligen sowjetischen Flugplatz zählen mit Gigabit-Internet am Nordbock?
Und es ist wohl so, dass es da keinen Platzbruch gibt?
Nein, es gibt keinen Platzproblem. Im Gegensatz zum Kongress im Winter. Also von daher sollte man davon Gebrauch machen. Außerdem ist das einfach schön unter freiem Himmel, bei lauschiger Nacht mit absolut außergewöhnlicher Beleuchtung. Es wird da wirklich ganz tolle Beleuchtung geben. Da einfach dann abzuhängen und zu diskutieren und Party zu machen. Das ist einfach mal ganz, ganz toll. Also wer das verpasst, ist selber schuld.
Und das alles im kleinen Maßstab gibt es ja, wie ich immer wieder von euch höre. Jeden Donnerstag kann man im Club vorbeikommen. Von wann bis wann ist das nochmal?
Von 17 Uhr bis Mitternacht glaube ich.
Genau, aber bitte da das Zelt zu Hause lassen.
Da steht schon so viel rum in dem Club.
Aber kennenlernen kann man euch da. So, dann also viel Spaß mit dem Chaos Computer Club im Podcast, wenn ihr gerne mögt. Demnächst dann hier geht es gleich weiter mit Flo Heiler im Night Flight. Wir verabschieden uns, Nibbler, Maha, vielen Dank fürs Vorbeikommen. Und ja, ihr kennt den Abschluss. Jetzt gibt es eigentlich nur noch eins zu sagen.